they was will about the Bachelorette and
reality TV but last night frontrunner
Jordan Rogers exposed these painful
truth about his broken relationship with
his NFL superstar brother Aaron and this
is real Nancy we're gonna head to this
to me when we spoke to Aaron girlfriend
Olivia Munn
she says tonight's top story the Rodgers
with exposed me Aaron don't really have
that much of a relationship this is kind
of the way he's chosen to do life I
chose to stay close with my family and
my parents the Bachelorette along with
most of America was surprised by
jordan's revelation but he and his super
bowl-winning brother aaron rodgers are
estranged Aaron's girlfriend Olivia mine
actually told us something similar in
May I'm very excited about your
boyfriend's brother being on The
Bachelorette or is it true um I I don't
know I
Aaron doesn't really he's not I don't
think he's really talked to his brother
so I actually don't know so what
happened it's it's complicated I'll say
that Jordan was vague in a recent
podcast but here's a timeline of what we
uncovered this is the last footage of
the brothers together working out way
back in 2011 in Vegas in 2014 they hit
the red carpet at the same time but
posed at opposite ends and it doesn't
end there several sources tell et that
Aaron is actually estranged from his
entire family and has been for years
we scanned social media and found the
family has posted lots of photos over
the years but we didn't spot Aaron in
any of them and there's more drama
coming Joe Joe asked Aaron and Jordans
oldest brother Luke about the rift next
week during a hometown visit I know the
whole situation with your brother Aaron
today we spoke to a source close to the
family who told us quote the entire
situation is painful for the family I
didn't realize this wound was as deep as
it